Allein auf dem Mars gestrandet
muss der Botaniker Mark Watney
monatelang in einer lebensfeindlichen
Welt überleben, bis seine Crew ihn mit
einem krassen Stunt rettet. Das ist die
mega-spannende Story von “Der Marsianer”.
Und natürlich habe ich mich gefragt: Könnte
“Der Marsianer” wirklich so passieren? Würde
ein Mark Watney wirklich allein auf dem Mars
überleben und könnte so eine wahnwitzige
Rettungsaktion wirklich funktionieren? Das
beantworten wir heute mit zwei Experten,
von denen eine wirklich schon mal eine
1-jährige Marsmission gemacht hat.
Und ich kann schon mal so viel
verraten: Vieles im Film stimmt,
aber es gibt mindestens einen Punkt, der
die ganze Geschichte kollabieren lässt!
“Der Marsianer” von Ridley Scott
soll besonders realistisch sein.
Und die Buchvorlage ist natürlich
noch viiieeel besser! Tatsächlich
soll der Autor Andy Weir sich tief in die
wissenschaftlichen Themen reingefuchst
haben. Aber stimmt das wirklich? Um das zu
überprüfen, haben wir 2 Experten eingeladen.
Volker Schmid ist Luft- und
Raumfahrt-Systemingenieur
und war viele Jahre lang zuständig für die
ISS und Astronautik beim DLR. Dabei hat er
tagtäglich mit Astronauten wie Alexander
Gerst und Matthias Maurer gearbeitet.
Dr. Christiane Heinicke ist Forscherin
für angewandte Raumfahrttechnologie
und beschäftigt sich damit, wie man
Mars-Stationen für Menschen bauen kann.
Und sie hat sogar schon für ein Jahr auf dem
Mars verbracht! Natürlich nicht auf dem echten,
sondern in einer simulierten
Mars-Station auf Hawaii.
Dort lebte sie mit einer realistisch
zusammengesetzten Crew auf engem Raum
zusammen. Essen, Wasser, Sauerstoff:
alles war rationiert. Mit der Außenwelt
konnten sie nur mit 20 Minuten
Verzögerung kommunizieren. Und
rausgehen ging nur in einer sorgfältig
geplanten Außenmission im Raumanzug.
ich war auf dem simulierten Mars , als der Film
rauskam und die Produktionsfirma hat uns den dann
tatsächlich zur Verfügung gestellt, dass wir
auf dem Mars den Marsianer gucken konnten.
Perfekte Experten, also, um über Marsmissionen
zu reden. Wir klären Fragen wie “Wo kommt der
Sauerstoff her?”, “Wie kommuniziere
ich mit den Menschen auf der Erde?”
und “Wie würde die Station auf
dem Mars in echt aussehen?”.
Die Station hat Vorräte, die schon
vor den Astronauten mit einigen
Versorgungsflügen angeliefert
wurden. Das ist realistisch.
Ob die Astronauten die Station gebaut haben oder
die Station sich robotisch selbst errichtet hat,
das wissen wir nicht – zumindest nicht im
Film. Man arbeitet allerdings in der Realität
definitiv an vollautomatischen Lösungen.
Es wäre für die Astronauten ja einfacher
und sicherer, wenn bei ihrer Ankunft schon eine
funktionsfähige Station auf sie warten würde.
Ein Hauptproblem ist Wasser. Es gibt zwar Wasser
auf dem Mars, aber die Station hat keine externe
Wasserquelle. Watney ist also komplett auf die
Wasseraufbereitung angewiesen. Dazu gibt es
tatsächlich heute schon brauchbare Technologien,
die zum Beispiel auf der ISS eingesetzt werden.
Etwa 80 - 90 % des Urins
wird wiederverwendet. Und:
Wenn jemand Sport treibt und schwitzt,
dann diese Luftfeuchtigkeit geht auch
ins System und es wird auch rausgezogen.
Um den Geschmack muss man sich
da übrigens keine Sorgen machen,
das wird natürlich alles gefiltert. Aber
der Kreislauf ist noch nicht perfekt und
die ISS braucht auch heute noch
zusätzliche Wasserlieferungen.
Auch die autonome Sauerstoff-Versorgung im
Film ist realistisch. Das hat der Prototyp
“MOXIE” dieses Jahr erst bewiesen. Der wurde
mit dem aktuellen Mars-Rover "Perseverance" zum
Mars geschickt und getestet. Zunächst
verdichtet er die dünne Mars-Luft,
die aus rund 95% Kohlendioxid besteht.
Dann macht er mittels Elektrolyse aus zwei
Molekülen CO2 – zwei Moleküle Kohlenmonoxid
und ein O2. Bei Abschluss des Tests im
September 2023 konnte die NASA verkünden:
Es hat besser funktioniert, als erhofft!
Aber ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt fehlt
beim Marsianer: der Strahlenschutz.
Wenn ich mir das Habitat anschaue,
wie es im Film dargestellt ist,
da ist kein Strahlenschutz. Und es gibt ja
weltweit eine ganze Reihe von analog Habitaten,
die für Mars-Simulationen, gebaut
worden sind keines davon hat einen
Strahlenschutz oder wenigstens ein
Konzept für den Strahlenschutz.
Für die “Humans on Mars”-Initiative, an der
Christiane mitarbeitet, ist Strahlenschutz
aber ein großes Thema – schließlich
ist die Belastung auf dem Mars 40-50
Mal so hoch wie auf der Erde.
Der beste Strahlenschutz wäre,
die Station in Wasser einzuhüllen. Tonnenweise
Wasser. Das ist natürlich schwierig auf dem Mars.
Die zweitbeste Lösung ist deshalb, das Habitat in
Regolith zu verpacken. Das ist der feine Staub,
der dem Mars seine Farbe verleiht. Auch davon
bräuchte es meterdicke Wände. Aber wir sehen
nichts davon in dem Film. Es besteht also ein
massives Krebsrisiko für Matt Damon. Und das
würde in Realität wohl niemand eingehen wollen.
Aber vermutlich wollte man einfach die schöne
Station auch von außen zeigen können.
Es sei den Filmemachern also verziehen.
Der Regolith bringt uns auch
gleich zu dem Teil des Films,
der vielen am Besten im Gedächtnis geblieben
ist. Es geht um Kartoffeln, Knallgas und Kacke.
Kurz nachdem Mark Wattney wegen eines
Sandsturms allein auf dem Mars gestrandet ist,
stellt er fest: Bis die nächste Marsmission
ankommt, wird er verhungern. Aber der Botaniker
findet Kartoffeln unter den Rationen.
Also baut er einen Acker mit Regolith,
erzeugt zusätzliches Wasser und benutzt den
gefriergetrockneten Kot der Crew als Dünger.
Das Wasser stellt er her, indem er den
Treibstoff Hydrazin zu Wasserstoff und
Stickstoff spaltet und dann den Wasserstoff
mit Sauerstoff in einer Knallgasreaktion zu
Wasser reagieren lässt. Dabei bringt er sich fast
um, aber prinzipiell könnte das schon klappen.
Eine richtig dumme Idee ist
aber der Regolith-Acker.
Ich würde Mars-Regolith nicht ins Innere
des Habitats holen. Also zum einen,
ja. Ich meine, es ist Staub. Klar, den kann ich
einatmen. Zum anderen der der Regolith. – Ich
glaube, das hat man rausgefunden, nachdem das
Buch schon geschrieben war – Der Regolith enthält
an vielen Stellen auf dem Mars Perchlorat
und Perchlorate sind für Menschen giftig.
Und nicht nur für Menschen, sondern auch für
Pflanzen. Da ändert auch der Kot der Crew
nichts dran. In Simulationsversuchen auf der
Erde reichte einfache Düngung auch gar nicht,
um den simulierten Mars-Regolith zu einem
brauchbaren Boden zu machen. Und auch die
notwendigen Boden-Organismen gibt es im Kot
nicht – und schon gar nicht im Mars-Regolith.
Also: Spannend, leider unrealistisch,
aber noch nicht der größte Plotbrecher!
Ein grundlegendes Problem von Mark Watney
ist also so offensichtlich, wie einfach:
Auf dem Mars fehlt es an natürlichen Rohstoffen!
Dinge, die für uns selbstverständlich sind,
wie Erde, Mikroorganismen oder allein das
Wetter sind essentielle Bausteine des Lebens.
Fehlt eins davon, bricht direkt Chaos aus. Das
zeigt mal wieder, wie genial unsere Erde ist.
Wenn ihr das auch feiert, dann könnte eine Uhr
oder Schmuck von Holzkern etwas für euch sein.
Uhren von Holzkern bestehen aus natürlichen
Materialien, primär natürlich aus Holz,
daher auch der Name. Dieses Modell ist
aber beispielsweise auch wasserdicht,
weshalb ich sie zum Duschen gar nicht ablegen
muss. Mit dem hochwertigen Quarzuhrwerk der Marke
Seiko ist sie dazu auch noch sehr präzise und muss
nicht täglich geladen werden, wie eine Smartwatch.
Wenn eine Uhr aber nichts für euch ist, dann
hat Holzkern auch noch ganz viele andere schicke
Accessoires im Angebot [On-Screen: Sonnenbrille
und Schmuck]. Und egal wofür ihr euch entscheidet,
die Produkte von Holzkern werden alle in
Kleinserien per Hand gefertigt. Es sind
also immer stark limitierte Auflagen
und ihr bekommt immer ein Unikat.
In der Videobeschreibung findet ihr neben
einem Link zum 15% Doktor-Whatson-Rabatt
noch einen Link zum Instagram-Profil von
Holzkern. Für alle, die interessiert sind,
lohnt es sich, Holzkern zu
folgen. Es könnte nämlich sein,
dass es sehr bald zeitlich begrenzte, aber
preislich sehr interessante Angebote gibt.
Schauen wir uns Watneys nächstes Problem an:
Wie sende ich ein Lebenszeichen zur NASA?
Für die Kommunikation will Watney die
Plattform einer früheren Mission benutzen:
Pathfinder. Pathfinder und ihr
Rover Sojourner erkundeten 1997
für 3 1/2 Monate ferngesteuert den Mars
– naja, ein ganz kleines bisschen davon.
Watney fährt mit einem von zwei
ziemlich robusten und großen
elektrischen Fahrzeugen zu der Stelle hin.
Tagelang. Immer wieder muss er pausieren,
um das Fahrzeug mit Sonnenenergie aufzuladen.
Nun kostet es wahnsinnig viel Geld und Ressourcen
gleich zwei große und schwere Rover zum Mars
zu schicken. Sind die Rover also realistisch?
Also ich habe selber schon in so einem
Teil drin gesessen 2018 sie brauchen einen
gewissen Raum . Man muss da auch mal eine
Nacht drin schlafen können. Es ist wie ein
Camper gleichzeitig auch Und ja, solche
Rover sind ausgelegt für Expeditionen,
die einen vom Habitat in einem bestimmten
Aktionsradius herumführen. . Sie müssen
robust sein, sie müssen lange halten.
Auch sie brauchen Strahlenschutz.
Ok, gut und Watney hat großes Glück: Während
die modernste Technologie seiner Station nach
wenigen Tagen auf dem Mars zerstört wurde,
ist Pathfinder nach fast 40 Jahren immer
noch funktionsfähig. Früher hat man
halt noch Wert auf Qualität gelegt!
Die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten von Pathfinder
sind aber begrenzt. Die NASA holt deshalb die
ehemaligen Pathfinder-Ingenieure aus
dem Ruhestand. Sie sollen helfen,
die Kommunikation zu verbessern. Dazu benutzen
sie eine Kopie von Pathfinder als Modell.
Das wird auch so gemacht, dass man wirklich
Modelle von dem hat, was man zum Mars schickt und
da an diesen Modellen dann eben das ausprobiert,
was man auf dem Mars ausprobieren möchte.
Watney kann dann per Textnachrichten mit der
NASA kommunizieren. Immerhin. So kann die NASA
ihm erklären, wie er vom Mars wegkommen
kann. Und das ist ein waghalsiger Stunt.
Als sein Team zur Erde kommt, nutzen sie in einem
Sling-Shot-Maneuver die Gravitation der Erde,
um gleich wieder Richtung Mars zu beschleunigen.
Wenn ihr Schiff, die Hermes, am Mars ankommt,
muss sich Watney “einfach nur” im richtigen
Moment mit einer Rakete in den Orbit schießen,
damit die Crew ihn einfangen kann. Aber
die Hermes kommt wegen des neuen Kurses
höher und schneller an als das Mars Return Module
fliegen kann. Deshalb muss Watney improvisieren.
Er muss die Kapsel 5 Tonnen leichter machen. Viele
lebenswichtige Systeme und sogar die Fenster und
die Spitze der Rakete sollen raus. Stattdessen
soll er eine Abdeckplane über die Kapsel ziehen.
Die Marsluft, die ist ja so dünn,
also der der Luftwiderstand,
die Bremsdrücke oder der Staudruck, der
da herrscht, der ist vernachlässigbar.
Ein kleiner Kern Wahrheit steckt also schon hinter
der Idee… aber realistisch ist das leider nicht.
Watney macht also die Kapsel leichter, die Hermes
kommt, er startet. Aber die Plane reißt ab,
der Luftwiderstand wird doch zu groß und er
erreicht trotz allem nicht die notwendige Höhe.
Deshalb muss jetzt die Hermes ihre Geschwindigkeit
drosseln. Mit einer selbstgebastelten Bombe
sprengen sie eine Luke. Die schlagartig
ausströmende Luft bremst das Schiff.
Ich will nicht sagen der schlechteste
Moment im Film, aber da hat es
für mich wehgetan, weil das
sollte man echt nicht machen.
Und die Aktion hat nicht mal gereicht. Der Abstand
zwischen Watneys Kapsel und der
Hermes ist immer noch zu groß.
Deshalb geht die Kommandantin mit einer
“Man Meneuvering Unit” auf Außenmission,
um Watney einzufangen und natürlich
ist ihre Sicherheitsleine zu kurz.
Kurzentschlossen schneidet Watneys seinen
Handschuh auf, um die ausströmende Luft
als Antrieb zu benutzen. Wir sehen,
wie einfach das zu kontrollieren ist.
Es ist Wahnsinn, ja – Aber auf der
anderen Seite Ich habe auch gelernt,
manchmal ist zwei plus zwei gleich fünf.
Und das muss man gelten lassen bei solchen
Missionen oder Herausforderung. Und das
braucht man auch das ist das Salz in der
Suppe, sag ich mal. Ob es hier natürlich
stimmt… ja klar. Müsste man nachrechnen.
Ok, also riskant, aber kann vielleicht klappen.
Manchmal muss man wohl einfach hoch pokern.
Bis hierhin gab es gute und weniger gute
Stellen. Aber alles war bisher immer
sehr gute Unterhaltung. Aber jetzt gibt es noch
einen ganz zentralen Punkt, der eigentlich den
ganzen Plot des Films zerstört. Und auf den
wird im Film sogar immer wieder hingewiesen!
Die Atmosphäre auf dem Mars besteht zu rund
95% aus Kohlendioxid. Außerdem beträgt der
Luftdruck auf dem Mars mit sechs Millibar
nur etwa 1/170 von dem auf der Erde! Deshalb
muss man ja die Fluchtkapsel vielleicht
tatsächlich nur mit einer Plane abdecken.
Aber, wenn man zu genau darüber
nachdenkt – und das tun wir jetzt
einfach mal – reißt genau
das die gesamte Story ein.
Auf dem Mars gibt es häufig
spektakuläre Stürme. Dabei
entstehen hohe Windgeschwindigkeiten und der
feine Mars-Regolith erzeugt Staubwolken bis
50 km Höhe. Genau so ein Sturm strandete
Watney am Anfang der Geschichte auf dem
Mars. Die Crew startet ja, weil der
Sturm die Rakete umzukippen droht.
Aber nichts von dem wäre passiert! Denn, zwar
sehen solche Marsstürme beeindruckend aus…
Aber dadurch, dass die Atmosphäre so extrem dünn
ist, fühlt sich so ein Sturm von – was weiß ich,
400 Kilometer pro Stunde – fühlt sich an
wie so ein laues Lüftchen auf der Erde.
Das schlimmste an so einem Sturm ist
deshalb, dass Geräte wie Solarpanels,
Rover und Satellitenschüsseln mit Staub
bedeckt werden. Aber das war’s dann auch schon.
Alles in allem hat Andy Weir also
seine Hausaufgaben gemacht. Aber es
gibt eben doch noch einige Stellen,
wo ihm der Spannungsbogen wichtiger
war als der Realismus und
das ist auch vollkommenokay!
Am Ende wollen wir unterhalten
werden undkein Paper lesen.
wenn schon ein bisschen echte Science im
Film steckt, bin ich persönlich glücklich.
Wenn ihr auch unterhalten werden wollt,
aber auch gleichzeitig etwas über Wissenschaft erfahren wollt,
vor allem in Filmen, dann ist "Wissenschaftler Reagieren" bestimmt was für Euch.
Das ist ein monatlicher Livestream, den wir für Arte auf Twitch machen,
wo wir immer mit einer Wissenschaftlerin und einem Wissenschaftler einen Science Fiction Film gucken
und den bewerten. Das Ganze geht nochmal viel mehr in die Tiefe, ist um einiges länger
und macht immer sehr sehr viel Spaß zuzugucken
Link dazu ist auch unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ansonsten an Euch: vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen und bleibt neugierig, Euer Cedric.